supongamos que tenemos una función
continua efe en un intervalo a como b
entonces f es continua continua continua
en el intervalo a coma de agua que
déjame dibujar una gráfica rápidamente
para ver cómo se vería entonces por acá
tenemos el eje llegué acá déjame ponerle
que es el eje que sale después voy a
utilizar la equis para otra cosa
entonces no quiero usar la horita
entonces vamos a poner que por aquí va
la gráfica algo más o menos de ese
estilo de modo que esto de aquí esta
gráfica corresponde a ye ye igual a efe
dt bueno sabemos que éste es continua en
la ave así que déjame marcar estos
puntos digamos por acá a este le voy a
llamar a y déjame poner una línea pues
así como que punteada más o menos y por
otro lado por acá esta verdad ve también
una línea punteada hasta ahorita no ha
hecho gran cosa simplemente grafica una
función continuada com ave pero
imagínate que ahora queremos encontrar
una expresión que nos dé el área que
está por debajo de esta función entre a
y un cierto punto x
en el intervalo pues bueno esto tampoco
es nada nuevo verdad ya hemos estado
platicando en los vídeos pasados que
esto tiene muchísimo que ver con una
integral de hecho es la definición que
hemos estado manejando de integral
entonces al intentar determinar esto de
acá verdad bueno para encontrar esta
área lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar la integral de x ahorita lo
pongo df de t de t entonces le pongo de
a ax muy bien pero ve esta expresión de
acá pues funciona para cualquier valor
de x entre a y b le voy a poner aquí que
funciona para x en el intervalo el
intervalo acabe le pongo a coma ve muy
bien entonces esto que nos sugiere bueno
ya que es una expresión que funciona
para muchos valores de x pues vamos a
llamarla a esta de acá una cierta
función entonces a esta expresión le
vamos a llamar f grandota de x va
entonces lo que estamos haciendo es
pensar que vamos a ir variando la equis
y eso nos da algunos valor
y con estos valores podemos construir
una función entonces efe grandota de x
nos da el área entre a y x vale ok hasta
ahorita no he dicho nada pues demasiado
increíble pero de lo que te quiero
platicar en este vídeo es del teorema
fundamental del cálculo teorema
fundamental fundamental mental de él
muy bien y que dice este teorema
fundamental del cálculo que suena tan
importante
pues dice una vez que tomamos está efe
grandota de equis y la intentamos
derivar o si así si queremos encontrar
la derivada de f con respecto a equis o
bien cambiando efe por lo que vale o sea
si queremos encontrar la derivada con
respecto a x de esta expresión de acá
déjame la escribo de la integral de f de
t de t de a a b de a x perdón de a
a equis o sea si queremos derivar efe
grandota o si queremos derivar esto lo
único que tenemos que hacer es poner efe
de hecho entonces que la derivada es
igual a efe de x muy bien esto ya que es
un resultado padrísimo sale y es súper
importante seguro te has de estar
preguntando por qué se llama fundamental
que es lo que es es tan fundamental en
este resultado de acá déjame meterlo en
una caja y lo que sucede es que este
teorema fundamental del cálculo pues ve
número uno déjame ponerlo aquí número
uno nos dice que cualquier función
continua cualquier función continua
función continua continua
efe tiene anti derivada tiene anti
derivada anti derivada
efe grandota y esto es un hecho
importante verdad esto está padre por sí
mismo ese es el punto número uno y bueno
además nos dice quién es la anti
derivada pero lo que es más
impresionante todavía es que este
teorema fundamental del cálculo
relaciona dos conceptos súper
importantes hasta ahorita la integral
hemos estado pensando como un área
verdad como el área de una región y la
derivada como una pendiente pero este
teorema fundamental del cálculo
relaciona esos dos conceptos de hecho es
lo que nos justifica este para llamar a
una integral una anti derivada entonces
punto número 2 establece una conexión
una conexión
entre derivadas entre derivadas
derivadas e integrales e integrales
eso está súper padre verdad derivar a
integrar son dos conceptos muy
importantes en cálculo y por eso es el
teorema fundamental ok ahora te has de
estar preguntando ok bueno aquí tenemos
el teorema fundamental del cálculo pero
cómo le hago para utilizarlo entonces
vamos a hacer esto ahorita si después
platicaremos de la intuición que está
detrás pero ahorita no voy a ver muy
práctico y básicamente te voy a mostrar
un ejemplo de cómo utilizar esto digamos
en un contexto de clase
entonces supongamos que nos piden
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
de la integral ese signo quedó muy feo
de la integral de coseno cuadrado bueno
de la integral de pi tengo que ponerle
extremos porque es integral definirá
verdad entonces nos piden derivar y con
respecto a x la integral de ti a x de
coseno cuadrado de t / / / no sea algo
bien feo logaritmo natural
dt menos raíz de t si una cosa
espeluznante va de t
dt bueno aunque esta cosa parezca
espeluznante pues estoy acá es una
función de x
tiene mucho que ver con esta verdad de
hecho es un caso particular donde la
avale pi y la ft es esta expresión
entonces lo que nos dice el teorema
fundamental del cálculo es que esto es
bien fácil de derivar simplemente lo que
está aquí adentro de hecho se puede ver
verdad simplemente es digamos que hacer
coincidir los patrones esto de aquí
adentro de la fdp entonces eso hay que
cambiarlo por una fx entonces los
lugares donde hay te lo cambiamos por
equis entonces derivar es facilísimo
esto simplemente es coseno cuadrado de
equis josé no cuadrado de x dividido
entre logaritmo natural de x menos raíz
de x va entonces pues básicamente fue
encontrar el patrón y esto si acaso es
un truco que se utiliza muchísimo en
competencias de cálculo digamos son de
estos problemas que tienen transita que
parece ser que tienes que integrar esta
cosa y luego derivarla pero no
simplemente lo que quieren es ver si te
acuerdas del teorema fundamental del
cálculo para entonces simplemente para
resolver estos problemas tenemos que
encontrar quienes de pdte y que tendría
que ser fx déjame escribir eso por qué
te ayuda un poco para cuando lo intentes
hacer tú entonces en este ejemplo de acá
esta expresión esta expresión lo que
está adentro de la integral es ft
step y es simplemente a y esta expresión
de acá esta expresión sería f de x era
una cosa padres que aquí a la derecha
pues no no pintó a entonces realmente no
dependió del extremo inferior sino
únicamente de que esto es una función
del extremo superior ok esto está
padrísimo le vamos a dejar hasta aquí
pero en los siguientes vídeos vamos a
hablar un poquito acerca de la intuición
detrás de esto de por qué pues será
cierto también practicaremos algunos
ejemplos más e incluso tal vez veamos
una prueba de este resultado súper
fundamental